this program is brought to you by Emory
University
close to a cure I will not say that I I
will say that certainly we have to work
on it and there is new new hope let's
say we have a proof of concept today of
HIV cure
you probably heard about what we call
the Berlin patient this patient that was
hiv-positive he's originally from United
States and was staying in in Germany and
he developed leukemia and the the
physician in Germany at the idea for
treating the patient for his leukemia to
make a bone-marrow transplant with a
donor that as the deletion invitation in
one of the co-receptor of HIV the ccr5
molecule so he got the bone marrow
transplant and he's what he was at a
time and antiretroviral treatment of
course because he was HIV positive but
then after the bone marrow transplant
and of course he was treated also with
drug for immunosuppressive drug like
always for a bone marrow transplant it
turned out that the virus became not
detectable at all in that patient and
still today the Berlin patient is living
without any integrity of our treatment
and the virus is not detectable in a
different compartment of his body so
this is a proof of concept that a cure
should be possible and of course the
approach of making bone marrow
transplant with Delta 32 deletion and
ccr5 so finding the donor and so on we
cannot use that at very large scale but
it's a very nice proof of concept
I'm personally I'm very positive for at
least what we call a functional cure
which means that we will not totally
eradicate the virus but at least we
should be able to control persistent
persistently control the virus in the
body why I'm so optimistic is because we
have also few cases you know less than
0.3 percent of people living with HIV
they never receive any antiretroviral
treatment and they are able to control
naturally control their infection
we call them elite controllers and those
elite controllers we know that a group
of them have a very strong t-cell
response capable to suppress the
infection and we are learning from a
server group of elite controllers
showing that they have a restriction of
infection of their cd4 cells and
macrophages and we are trying to
understand the mechanism of this
restriction of HIV infection of target
cells
so I mean there is new avenue let's say
for research today on HIV cure and the
reason why at the International
associate II we decide like it is you're
the role of the society to try to
promote stimulate and connect scientists
at international level to work together
on this direction of HIV cure
you
the preceding program is
University